este lúgubre sótano se convirtió en el
hogar de nadie y tengo galina que os sus
familiares y vecinos luego de que las
tropas rusas tomaron el pueblo de mala
rogan en la región de jarquín dos
semanas después del inicio de la guerra
con ucrania durante tres días nos
quedamos con nuestros amigos salimos de
nuestra casa sin nada sin documentos a
pesar del temor y las limitaciones estas
valientes mujeres se enfocaron en
sobrevivir y en proteger a los suyos
cocinaban en una estufa de leña
improvisada para poder alimentar a sus
familias mientras los rusos bombardeaban
su pueblo y los soldados se acercaban a
su refugio una situación aterradora para
galina poco movimiento fin y los
primeros no fueron agresivos con
nosotros incluso preguntaron si podían
usar nuestro sótano en el patio dijeron
que podíamos quedarnos en nuestra casa
pero luego hubo otro grupo unos tres
días después fueron más agresivos
teníamos un perro le dispararon hasta
los trabajos de estribela ahora que las
tropas rusas se han retirado de su
pueblo
y nadie no sólo se enfrentan a la ardua
tarea de reconstruir sus hogares sino
también sus vidas pero no pierden las
esperanzas
esto aquí se puede reconstruir creemos
que podemos hacerlo todo esto se
reconstruyera somos lo suficientemente
fuerte para reconstruir todo lo que han
destruido y andrés díaz en la región
dejar que el 90% de las viviendas han
sido destruidas por rusia según las
autoridades locales